the jurogan experience this season it
was a lot of it was some baby steps of
like
going back to that route and just
placing a lot of gear so i felt super
safe
and then you know climbing it in the
same style that i was going to climb
with alex simon climbing it but still
placing
more gear and then during my try this
year i actually
told alex because he was he's definitely
um
more comfortable than almost anyone i
know on el cap most people at least feel
a little bit of
intimidation a little bit of fear like
you know there's a little bit of anxiety
around it and he's just it's so casual
that he was like yeah you should just
like you know just run it out like go
go all the way like he was basically
just wanting me to do it the same
way that i was doing it before and i was
like you know alex i'm gonna be a little
slower this time
like i just i think i need that for my
head
and so he felt like you should do it
with the same amount of gear that you
did before
just don't fall just don't fall this
time emily yeah kinda real simple a
little bit
yeah he was like you know but alex the
one thing he always says is
he's just like okay follow your heart
and i was like okay well i'm gonna go
slower
well just so the audience knows alex
told me
that he did a route once and
on his way up realized that he hadn't
brought any
chalk so he had to borrow it
from someone else he was strapped to
ropes so he's free soloing
yeah no chalk yeah says hey
uh i don't have any chalk and the guy
gives him a bag
and said he left the bag at the top so
that when they got to the top they could
retrieve the bag yeah that's a classic
alex situation
yeah what like how do you not
bring like if you lift weights you you
like
chalk it's like it's very important for
me to get a good grip kind of obsessed
with having chalk
i don't have chalk i just won't go
climbing i just can't imagine
but you know i think he's the type of
person that um
you know going back to like talking
about heart rate like i bet i bet when
he's in those types of situations like
he's so relaxed and his heart rate is so
low and he's just
he's a different i i think he's truly
unique
you know and i i think i i think that
he just has a different like even brain
chemistry than
than a lot of us in terms of like how he
feels fear and how
he can maintain that composure in a very
dangerous situation
well he's remarkably calm all the time
yeah like he just seems always like on
this one
plane yeah he's got like this like 55
beats per minute that he just stays at
all the time yep and it's great climbing
with him actually because it kind of
rubs off on me a little bit
like when i climb with alex i feel more
confident i feel more capable i tend to
climb better
um even though he kind of gives me
all the time for being nervous he's
always like you're always nervous like
you're
you're always stressing out but it's
actually when i'm with him i'm like you
know what i
i can chill out a little bit i can like
i can i can be on that wavelength a
little bit more so that's part of the
reason why
i like climbing with him up there and
why i chose him for this project well
that makes sense i mean
i guess when you're around people that
are if you're doing a thing
and you're around people that are
excellent at that thing it's
contagious or at least inspirational
yeah i mean i think it's important to
like
do yeah to practice practice things you
want to be better at with people who are
better than you yeah for sure
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available
everywhere but after december 1st they
will only be available on spotify but
they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love